oh man dave coulier is here
all right what's going on man how are
you what do we do yeah i'm i'm fine
i never know if people want to shake or
not
good to see you too good i never know if
people want to shake i i don't mind it
but some people just hate it and people
even before covert it was bad but like
after covert some people just don't want
to touch at all yeah i don't throw up on
people that's what i don't know
that's good you guys don't care if i
puke
just a little
you got to draw your lines where you can
draw them you know is that what finally
made you quit drinking was it the
vomiting the vomiting is is probably the
worst part of it i wasn't a i wasn't a
puker no i wasn't you know i was just uh
a blanker outer
you know to where people go you were so
funny last night did you ever get those
underpants off your head yeah
you know so it was like i don't remember
that i have full pockets of time in my
life that are just gone yeah that's
probably worse than losing your lunch
losing time from your life yeah it's
terrifying too it's terrifying and i was
i was a faller you know where you know
and i was always i've been a hockey
player my whole life so i'm always the
final final final guy sitting around
with the guys after the game having
beers you know i was that guy and i
would fall and like the last time i fell
my wife was out of town and a buddy of
mine laughed and he goes oh that's going
to leave a mark
and i looked and he took a picture and
he goes you got to send that to your
wife because melissa's coming home in
two days and that's not going to heal up
and i said okay so i sent it to her and
she just screamed and started crying and
i realized okay i got to take a second
look at this
yeah yeah your loved ones are screaming
yeah
yeah which for me it's normally when i
send it nude
do you uh would she be on you all the
time like hey you got to stop you got to
stop no no no i i got the best wife in
the world she uh
just you know is concerned but uh when i
quit drinking she quit drinking she's
like you know what i'm gonna support you
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know
no more wine with dinner or anything i'm
just gonna i'm gonna stick close to you
on this so she's been really supportive
it's been great was it difficult like to
to get through or once you were once you
were there were you there it led up i
there was like a year of leading up to
it where i was like i got to make some
changes but it took me a year to kind of
discover like
relationships that had kind of frayed at
the edges and my creativity wasn't there
and i didn't feel like jumping up on
stage and just you know things it had
diminishing returns so it took me about
a year to kind of figure all that out
and kind of com
compartmentalize everything like am i
going to be funny again yeah am i going
to be like the final final guy who's
funny with everybody and i that was the
thing i worried about the most was am i
going to be funny
yeah so
you know i processed all that and then i
just decided january 1st 2020. that's it
did your blackout during the show i
never went on drunk do you have your
blackout like midshoga whatever i did i
was yes i did i was at uh yuck yucks in
vancouver and uh first show right out of
the gate and the night before i'd been
out drinking with uh some of the detroit
red wings staff
and we were talking hockey till five in
the morning and then i had two shows
that night
and i'm about five minutes into my set
and just i heard this high-pitched hum
in my head
couldn't remember the next line
and i just said to the audience hold on
just one second i went behind the
curtain and they have that microphone
where they introduced the next comic
standing back there so i started blowing
hand farts into the microphone
listening to the audience laugh and i'm
panicking going what do i say next so so
the opening comment comes over and i go
go grab in my bag in the comics room
grab my my uh piece of paper and it had
my set written on it so he went and
grabbed that and i went oh my god i'm
only five minutes
and i walked back out and some of my
friends who were there said that thing
you did where you walk backstage and
we're blowing farts is the funniest
thing i've ever seen in my life i said i
don't think i'll be doing that bit again
yeah it's a panic move yeah right yeah
is it also like i mean it's got to be
more pressure for you too because it's
not just like you know this famous
comedian
blacked out on stage at yuck yucks what
you don't want is like hey what's joey
from full house up to oh he blacked out
on stage at yuck yuck you know it
becomes a much bigger
story because of kind of who you are
yeah and i said to my wife melissa i
said hey you know i'm gonna post this
picture just because i'm tired of like
not telling people about it and i just
feel like so what you know who i am it's
where i've been yep i was a i was a
drinker yeah you know i was an alcoholic
and so she said well just get ready and
i go i don't think anybody's gonna care
she goes just get ready i'm telling you
and it just kind of opened up this whole
new world of people perceiving me in a
different way but it's probably positive
right people probably supportively
unbelievable yeah yeah jim it was it was
amazing
and you know i i don't like to be
preachy or pious about it you know i'll
buy my buddy's shots you know when we're
sitting around i don't i don't mind that
but if somebody can just see themselves
in my story and go well if that guy can
you know
be abused by alcohol
um maybe i can maybe i can find sobriety
too so i mean you know
everybody's on a different totally
different level and
different point in their life yeah when
did you realize because like you were
part of not just full house but like so
many things that i i don't even know if
people like realize like you know the
ghostbusters cartoon and muppet babies
even for me like
out of control like when i was a little
kid
before full house came on and when full
house came on you were the guy from
out of control to me that show
go ahead no you go ahead i want to hear
about out of control that show was such
a gift i was 23 years old and i was
about to do the tonight show my first
one with johnny carson hosting and i was
you know you're not real confident as a
young comic you know especially when
that's kind of the only show for
comedians you know and then i got this
series out of control and the producer
bob hughes said we're going to let you
improv we're going to let you just
you're going to host this but whatever
you want to do and i thought this is
like
being in a comedy toy box where you can
play with any kind of toy you want and i
learned how to be a tv comedian you know
it was really where it was like you know
comedy college for me it was great you
know it was interesting because at the
time like it was on nickelodeon right
yeah but you could you could i feel like
in the 80s there
shows that were targeted for kids you
could still it wasn't so like you know
hey there little guy we're gonna you
could actually do stuff that would apply
to your real comedy career we weren't
selling toys right we were not you know
there was no marketing team there was
you know it was
nickelodeon based in canada at the time
and
they left us alone so we were cranking
out these shows down in la and it was
just me and the cast improving our way
through funny sketches that's awesome
how did how did the tonight show set go
i was scared to death i was scared to
death and i had gone with shandling to
his first eight tonight shows and gary
and i used to punch up his sets and
stuff so i kind of knew my way around
there with you know peter la sally and
jim mccauley you know they knew who i
was i was this young kid who wrote with
gary and so i kind of knew my way around
the tonight show and then i was sitting
with shanley at the improv one night and
uh jim mccauley comes over he goes i saw
your set you're on the show thursday i
said jim there's no way i'm not ready
i'm not ready and gary goes dave you
have to do the show
and i said gary i'm not ready he goes
you're ready you're ready ready and so
um he said i already spoke to brad who
was brad gray who was our manager and uh
he said you're on the show so i'll see
you i'll see you on monday and we'll go
over your set and i was terrified
because i really was not a tonight show
comic you know guys who are can craft a
joke you know like shandling and
stephen wright and jerry seinfeld i mean
those guys are so good at what they do
and i was a guy who was you know
i'm gonna do joe pesci okay okay okay
and i'm gonna do five minutes as joe
pesci you know so they kind of corralled
my set
and tried to make me a tonight show
comic i got the okay from johnny
but
they really didn't like what i did very
much because i was doing sound effects
and voices and you know and it was just
kind of what i did on stage at the time
you know because my focus was really
i want to be an actor i want to be in a
sitcom i want to keep doing voices
and so that's what i was doing on stage
but what's interesting is like that was
also the era where like they would try
to take your act and turn it into a
sitcom and you know like roseanne and
they did it with seinfeld too and
everything but when you got onto full
house you were doing
a lot of your stuff
as the character right or kind of you
know which was great the producers were
so
gracious that way they came out to uh
igbes in santa monica and watch my set
and so they incorporated they said oh we
want to do some of those funny voices
and things that you do into the show and
i thought oh this is perfect yeah did
you cut it out was yours
no i still cut it out did you and i'll
tell you who i stole it from he's my uh
oldest longest childhood friend his name
is mark sandrowski we we met in third
grade
back in detroit
and uh he has directed every episode of
the big bang theory wow he's a big
television director so we were thick as
thieves as kids
and he and his brother used to do
a comedy duo called ski squared
and uh they had some really funny stuff
but he would do this lounge singer like
bill murray and he would pull his shirt
open and show his nipple to some lady in
the front row he goes i know what you're
looking at now cut it out i told him i
said i'm going to steal that
you know so he said oh you owe me you
owe me i go get shut up
you're like the biggest tv director on
the planet knock it off you've got
plenty of cash
give me this give me this yeah what was
the
when you went to full house was there a
period of time between out of control
and full house or did you just go right
from one to the other there was yeah in
fact um i went on the road and uh
you know because i thought well i guess
i'm going to be a comic and tell so i
you know i did some i guessed it on new
heart and family ties and did a cheech
and chong movie called things are tough
all over so there were little jobs here
and there and then i auditioned for snl
and did my screen test at nbc
and uh
brad gray called me and he said you know
i just talked to uh i just talked to
lauren dave and he says uh it's gonna be
great having dave with us in new york
this year as a as a featured player and
so
you know i was going to new york to be
on saturday night live and so i told
everybody in my life of course you know
all the comics knew it like wow you're
going to new york you're on snl and i'm
like yeah can you believe it told
everybody i knew my family
boxed up everything in my apartment and
then like uh 10 days go by and i don't
hear anything and i'm trying to find an
apartment in new york
and i'm ready to go and then i get a
call from brad and he says uh listen i
got some bad news i'm like what could be
bad i didn't find an apartment
and he said no you're not going and i
said why and he said because i just
talked to brandon tartikoff and brandon
thinks you and dana carvey are too
similar
so i had to call everybody in my life
and say i'm not going i wasn't lying i
really was going and i luckily got my
apartment back unpacked everything and
then about a year later i got the full
house script
was every that year before you got full
house
when dana carvey was on snl
were you just grinding your teeth every
time
no i love comics you know i i
if somebody's successful i'm so happy
for them because it's so tough what we
do yeah that i'm happy when a comic is
is exploding you know because i know how
much work that is and i know how hard
dana worked because we would cross each
other at the clubs all the time and so i
was happy for him you know i was just
thinking
wow i am such a loser
like what's next and then i was
you know given that script for full
house and boom and then i i got it
and i thought well why was that so easy
did you after full house is done
because that's i mean you know such a
huge thing it's like it's defining you
for so many people
what do you
do like how do you kind of
get into this place where you're like
okay i'm going to figure out what life
is like beyond this i had uh four shows
canceled all at the same time really
real ghostbusters uh muppet babies
america's funniest people and uh full
house all ended at the same time and i
was so burned out by that time i was on
stage in detroit michigan at a place
called pine knob me and dennis miller
were co-headlining
and i walked off from that set being so
burned out i just thought this is it i'm
canceling all my stand updates i'm
burned out i have nothing funny to say
uh after eight years
and um so i did i cancelled my dates and
i walked off and i just said
i can't do this for a while so from that
respect it was kind of a self-chosen
decision yeah um and i just gone through
a divorce and my little boy luke was
just a little guy
he was only like four years old so i
thought i'm just gonna be a dad and i'm
gonna take time off and i'm gonna throw
a baseball with him and ride bikes and
just be a dad so i did that
and then i had to kind of decide okay
what's next when you uh
so you've got like like all these people
looking at you a certain way whether
it's you know ghostbusters or full house
or any of this stuff and you're a dad
and you're doing all this stuff and then
these alanis morissette rumors start
rearing their ugly head are you going
like i really
i don't need this out there right now or
are you like yeah this is it is what it
is
it was what it was yeah you know we
dated and she was writing all that
jagged little pill stuff during that
time and and i never saw this you know
angry white girl thing that she's
you know that people have kind of coined
her as i never saw that she was funny
she was sweet she was super intelligent
super talented um so i never i never saw
that but when people would you know that
was 95 when jagged little pill came out
and uh i started
here's the story
i'm driving in detroit
and i've got my radio on
and i hear the hook for you oughta know
come on the radio and i'm like wow this
is a really cool hook
and then i start hearing the voice i'm
like wow this girl can sing
and i had no idea you know that that
this was the record and i gave someone a
cross and then i
and then i was like
uh i'm listening to the lyrics going ooh
oh no
oh
i can't be this guy and i went to the
record store bought the cd and i went
and i parked on the street and i
listened to the whole record and there
was a lot of familiar stuff in there
that her and i had
talked about like your your shake is
like a fish you know i'd go hey dead
fish me you know and we'd do this dead
fish handshake and and so i started
listening to it and i thought ooh
i think i may have really hurt this
woman and that was my first thought and
so years later we reconnected
and uh she couldn't have been sweeter
and i said what do you want me to say
when people ask me about this
relationship and she said you can say
whatever you want
so she was really sweet about it she was
kind
um i'll tell you the kind of person she
is when my sister sharon was dying with
cancer
alanis was living in toronto my sister
was in detroit she actually drove to
detroit with her guitar
and sat with my sister playing songs and
singing to my sister in the hospital wow
that's the kind of human being she is so
i've never had anything bad to say about
her she's lovely yeah what uh now when
you're in that theater that she
references what movie were you watching
you know
you do that uh you do that popcorn cup
trick
one time and it backfires on you you
know
it it is ironic
by the way that was not fun
i didn't do that purpose i'm going to
rephrase my question because i didn't
have purpose
nothing i didn't say i'm not doing it
again i didn't
but
it's like we have a full house in here
but it's like of course it becomes the
most iconic
breakup song everything you do it feels
like there's it becomes iconic right
you're just a part of so much
iconography
in uh american entertainment it's kind
of unbelievable purely unintentional
right purely you know i guess you're
just an incredible person
well you can't it's it's tough to write
your own story you know and my story has
kind of been written for me in a lot of
ways
so it's just kind of like well ride
through that story the best you can yeah
i wrote my own story and i auditioned
for it and i didn't get it i think
was there ever when you were were you
did you still just stand up while full
house was on
i was yeah i was doing i was doing
stand-up did you was there ever any
trouble with that like were people
looking for the stuff from the show when
they went to see you or were audiences
generally cool about they were cool yeah
they were really cool you know and then
there was a period where i just i
couldn't get work you know i was the guy
from full house and things had changed
in television by that time
and uh
you know couldn't get arrested and then
you get over that hump and all of a
sudden everything's everything that was
old is new and
yeah and
you know i've always looked at this as
cyclical and a roller coaster ride and
you know um
just just if you're in for the long haul
which i always said i would be
uh through the good and through the bed
you know just ride it through as long as
it's still fun if it's still fun keep
doing it and if it's not do something
else yeah we should plug the show
properly uh it's called live and local
it's available exclusively on pureflix
new episodes every thursday and uh where
pureflix is that every how do you see
pureflix i don't know anything about it
go to pureflix.com yeah it's a new
streamer so people don't know about it
and that's my job so uh it's a new
streamer uh sony affirm is the you know
the studio
and uh they're streaming everything on
uh on pure flicks and it has kind of a
faith-based message not necessarily uh
they're trying to do more family
oriented stuff not so much heavy
faith-based stuff you know because me
even me as you know as a viewer if it's
like okay we panned down from a
sorrowful picture of jesus okay this is
gonna be funny yeah right you know so so
it is funny and that's all kind of just
working in the background so uh my hat's
off to them that that's what they're
trying to do now
um so it's been a it's been a really fun
show yes and i think that's it for us
today that's our show yes we're done